oh hey cut hint see if they're welcome
to hard time you know I'm not talking
about my my name is menace that is the
face of men is right there for us what
don't you [ __ ] understand however
that is not our name our name is solid
ass what's your pick
what salad ass what did you do it's
starting to look like me I'd okay
I don't give a thing I'm salad ass
you can't kill with salad it's what to
do
don't prostitution me oh I need a place
W is a [ __ ] [ __ ] hard man daddy
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry man I'm
selling ass you can't control the salads
ass all right right here hi friends I
hope we can get alone you're a snitch
salad ass he do you have to get to judge
if you dig I let him touch my salad ass
I did my salad dance
I did my salad dance and now that was it
well this is the most realistic prison
simulator I've seen him a left and I've
been to prison I've seen that [ __ ] up
close
okay well let's yeah you know let me
grab this brick and yeah it'll be my
defense hey solid ass I need that brick
yes give me yes give dynam all right
here you go how do you break thanks this
should come in handy
I can ask any questions about that give
up my friend how do you never know he
was my friend and what is my mouth look
like I'm not even speaking right now I'm
not even talking no forget it it's my
friend I don't know who he is but he's
my friend
why are you gonna kick the [ __ ] out of
me for that are you [ __ ] kidding you
know what you know what you know what
you know what my break my break now huh
bet you wish you wouldn't you wouldn't
have given me the Rick break you're my
only friend in this town Allah be pity
I'm so glad you saved me thank you so
much
whoa this brick is totally talking to me
that's so weird
what are you doing with that breaking oh
please don't take break away from me
he's my best friend
well that just makes me all more
suspicious no don't confiscate brick
please send copies all right get the
brick get the brick get the brick get
the brick get the brick that guy has a
[ __ ] axe who like the [ __ ] axe in
a jail brick we're back yes
nothing will stand away from me and
brick
[Music]
have you ever [ __ ] a brick pits I have
not but I will try look me and brick are
gonna watch a movie now
[Music]
[ __ ] this is a good movie set a [ __ ]
katana who left the [ __ ] katana
laying around in the prison felt like
brick needs a name though [ __ ] I threw
bricks Jesus Christ don't you touch
break his name is Rick oh [ __ ] I throw
him again Jesus Christ Jesus Christ
these guys no one picks up brick I mean
Rick hey no no no no no don't touch me
don't touch me and Rick you can earn
money by helping okay that's interesting
that's pretty cool watch me after he
says that oh [ __ ] he wants my break you
know that kind of thing doesn't belong
here
look behind you there's literally
thousands of bricks you he's not even
holding the Patong he's not even be
holding it right what a [ __ ] [ __ ]
Jesus Christ what's happening right now
can a man have a break as his friend in
a prison understood he did wanted a
break oh [ __ ] today's menu is green blob
plus of who threw that
but for [ __ ] sake I'm so done with
everyone kicking my [ __ ] ass in this
place of the [ __ ] sake what do you
want
what is it what is how is this a game
I'm [ __ ] dead all right
I'm [ __ ] dead you got me you kill me
Bravo
Rick hey at least we'll be together now
Rick I love you I love you so much me
[Music]
that was the best [ __ ] kid I've ever
played oh my god
I hope you really enjoy that I sure as
hell did click here to watch similar
videos if there aren't any we'll see
I'll see you the next one thank you for
watching and as always it's a yes in me
see why I say it's my favorite game
because I can change my underwear
they're all dirty I'm going for the
striped ones cos the stripes shows up
the curls of the girls but
[Music]